Trump reacting to Ron DeSantis claiming
he'll have eight years to improve the
country Trump's saying you really don't
need eight years I only need six months
when I hear the Sanctus when I hear the
sanctimonious come and say we need eight
years
again if he needs eight years don't vote
for him I'll have that this country will
be hopping in six months you know what's
funny Trump could become president and
then on the day of the inauguration
January 2025 if the economy looks like
it looks now Trump will just point to
the existing numbers he'll say look
unemployment's so low black unemployment
so low wages are up inflation's down
stock market steady
there is no of course the economy will
be hopping in six months
because the economy is doing fine right
now could we have a recession a
depression of course we always could but
this idea that it's a disaster and Trump
will fix it laughable laughable idea